julie i'm in the department of applied
physics at stanford and i'm going to
talk about mechanistic models of
cognition from perception to navigation
to semantic development
so i'd like to preface by saying of
course we're in a golden age of
neuroscience at the moment we have
access to large-scale recordings and
stimulation data
sciences and machine learning and
computation allow us to generate highly
accurate veritical models of brain
function at least in terms of predicting
the activity of individual neurons
but this raises a profound question
about the very nature of explanation in
neuroscience are we simply replacing
things that we would like to understand
but don't with something else that we
don't understand i.e replacing brains
with complex vertical models
so statistical and computational
neuroscience has a major understanding
problem and the theme of this talk is to
develop and apply
techniques in explainable artificial
intelligence to understand and extract
testable hypotheses about accurate but
complex neural models
explainable ai is a set of techniques or
a set of goals that aim to
try to trace the causal flow of
information through circuits and
understand how that information flows to
mediate function
okay
so um you know the outline of the talk
i'll give you four very high level kind
of take-home messages of four vignettes
that we've been working on in my lab
the first at the top is a
state-of-the-art model of the retinal
response to natural movies
and then we uh under we aim to
understand how it reproduces 20 years of
experiments on artificial stimuli
the second is to derive from first
principles the properties of the four
most dominant retinal ganglion cell
types from the structure of natural
movies
you know in the primate
okay
the third is to try to explain a
function a functional origin for grid
cells and we're going to derive a theory
for the obligatory emergence of grid
cells from biological neural plausible
neural circuits that path integrate
and uh
in the fourth we'll we'll go even higher
level to psychology we're going to
derive a simple theory of how neural
circuits can recapitulate diverse
psychology experiments
development of semantic categories uh in
infants okay so let's get started
um so
the the work on the network models of
the retina was done by a very talented
group of grad students and postdocs
there's a sequence of papers here which
will contain all the all of the details
so
uh here's a schematic of the retina it's
already a sort of a one hidden layer
neural network light comes in on the
photoreceptors that generates electrical
signals that propagate through a layer
of bipolar cells laterally connected by
horizontal and american cells and that
generates uh activity in retinal ganglia
cells and we have one million optic
nerve fibers that go to our brain that
tell us everything we know about the
visual world
a common model of the retina is a very
simple
uh linear nonlinear model consisting of
a spatial temporal linear filter of
light patterns
uh propagating through a rectifying
nonlinearity this is a very good model
of the retinal response to white low
resolution white noise but it can't
accurately get the retinal response to
um natural movies the very stimuli that
sculpted the evolution of the retina
and of course it doesn't it doesn't
reflect the underlying complexity of the
retina at all so we decided to try to
fit
a very uh a deep neural network model of
the retina that mimics the structure of
the retina
so it takes its input stimuli
generates a retinal ganglion cell
outputs and we try to adjust the
synaptic weights of this neural network
so it mimics the retinal response of
salamander retinal ganglion cells
while they're exposed to natural movies
this is data taken from steve bakus's
lab at stanford
remarkably our model provides highly
accurate predictions for the spike
trains of these retinal ganglion cells a
new held out natural movies that were
never shown to the model to train
it's its accuracy in predicting
performance is almost as high as
possible set by a noise ceiling due to
intrinsic stochastic in the retina
itself
other models like linear nonlinear
models or in orange or ganglion cells
sorry sorry glm models in green don't do
as well as our deep neural network which
is shown in the purple bar to the to the
top to the right
what's interesting is if you look at
hidden units in the hidden layers of our
models they behave a lot like bipolar
cells and american cells in the middle
left you see a black trace and a purple
trace the black trace is recordings from
a real bipolar cell and the purple trace
is uh quote unquote recordings from the
best matching hidden unit in our model
and you can see a very nice match and
the receptive fields match and uh
quantitatively and so forth but what's
interesting is now that we have a very
accurate model of the retinal response
to natural movies we asked like can it
recap recapitulate decades worth of
retinal physiology experiments on a
whole bunch of structured stimuli for
example these eight stimuli classes in
the bottom right
and remarkably despite never having seen
the stimuli it could accurately uh
reproduce all of these responses just to
show you uh just to show you an example
of of how striking these responses are
here are kind of three examples of these
non-linear retinal responses so for
example in the top if you show a full
field flashing grading to the retina the
retina will entrain to those full field
flashes but then if you emit a flash at
the very end the retina will fire a lot
it's as if the retina has learned
something about the the world
essentially its periodic structure and
when there's a violation of that
periodicity it sends a large complaint
to the brain and it works for a range of
frequencies okay
there's the motion reversal response in
the middle so if a bar is moving to the
right and then it suddenly reverses
direction
the retina will complain a lot all the
retinal ganglion cells receptor fields
are in the vicinity of the motion
reversal will complain a lot they'll
send a huge volume of spikes to the
brain so it's as if the retina knows
about newton's first law of motion
objects that that are in motion tend to
remain in motion and when newton's first
law is violated the retina sends a
signal of that violation to the brain
you know another phenomenon is when we
move our eyes to the right the entire
world moves to the left on our retina
but we don't have an internal perception
that the world is moving right so we can
segregate this global motion from a
local motion which
does signify a local object moving in
our in our field so for example
on the bottom right in this in this full
gray thing if you have a full field
grading just moving globally both inside
the circular receptor field and outside
of it
the cell won't fire a lot
okay but just above in panel a if you
have local motion that's out of phase
with the global motion in red
then the same cell will fire a lot so it
can detect specifically locomotion and
it filters out global motion
so these are
so the retina is acting like a
predictive engine it has important
aspects of a model of the dynamics of
the world and it signals violations of
that model so these are actually just
they're not arcane effects they're
actually central to how presumably the
retina operates what's striking is that
when we tested
the same model that was only trained on
natural movies this model at the top and
we tested in all of these eight stimuli
classes which included these three
stimuli classes that i went in and
explained it got every single one of
them right it displayed exactly the same
nominee responses
but now this raises again a profound
question about the very nature of
explanation in neuroscience
why is it that this complex neural model
you know complains when a flash is
emitted complains when a bar is reversed
these are qualitative phenomena and they
demand a qualitative intuitive
mechanistic explanation
but how do you go into the you know
thousands of parameters of this trade
neural network and extract from that
these these explanations
so um
so we would like to and moreover how do
we extract experimentally testable
hypothesis fees to drive the design of
insightful future experiments using this
complex model so the basic idea that we
followed is that we for each stimulus we
developed and advanced methods in
explainable artificial intelligence
to carve out from this large complex
circuit
important sub-circuits that were
responsible for generating the response
so for example in the emitted stimulus
response when there was a huge flash
we asked uh
you know when that flash occurred
how do we trace backwards in time the
causal flow of information through the
circuit
that then that led from stimulus to that
flash
and then we could carve out a
sub-circuit that led to that and we did
this for a lot of these classes of
stimuli and what we found here
is that um
for each of these classes of stimuli we
were able to take this complex model in
the middle and extract very very simple
circuits that were good for explaining
one of the phenomena
right and and remarkably in for for
three of these phenomena for latency
encoding motion anticipation motion
reversal we found sub-circuits that had
a lot of experimental support in the
literature in previous papers
right what's interesting is for the
emitted stimulus response nobody had
written down
a single model that could account for
all aspects of the response
we were able to extract a very simple
model involving three bipolar cell
pathways with different latencies and
different dominarities that when you put
them together and impinge them on a
ganglion cell it yields all aspects of
their emitted stimulus response
so so this model makes direct
predictions if you knock out a
particular type of bipolar cell you'll
have this differential effect on the
emits response and so forth so because
we can now understand this model and its
response to specific stimuli we can
actually make testable predictions and
again i should emphasize that nobody had
ever written down
a single model that account that could
account for all of these stimuli and
that's what we have here
so in some sense this work can
recapitulate about 20 years of work on
the retina
uh we have since uh expanded this work
to
primate retina and grid cells which i'll
talk about next
okay
so so the second part we're going to
derive from first principles the four
most dominant retinal gangle cell cell
types from the structure of natural
movies so here instead of trying to fit
a complex model to a brain circuit
we're not going to fit it at all we're
going to try to derive it from first
principles in order to try to attempt to
answer the why question
why is the primate retina
organized the way it is why does it use
these four cell types that it does okay
so um
you know there's a lot of effort in
experimental neuroscience going into
cataloging cell types in the brain
including in the brain initiative
um you know chan zuckerberg cell type
atlas allen brain institute and so forth
however there is no theory for why we
have so many cell types and we attempt
to address this in the retina and again
this is done by a very talented group of
students in postdocs
okay
so um just to review the biological
information
about 70 percent of all cell types in
the primate retina
are composed of [ __ ] and parasol cells
and they have the following salient
properties
the [ __ ] cells have a very small
receptive field in space
okay but they're slow the receptor field
in time is slow so they're slow
integrators
the parasol cells
have a large receptive field in space
and in time they integrate very very
fast there's a lot of [ __ ] cells and
they're very they're not very sensitive
they don't fire a lot the the um there's
very few parasol cells and they're very
sensitive they fire a lot in general
they have high firing rates
okay so the dominant question we'd like
to understand is why is space and time
intertwined in this fashion
why is a small spatial receptor field
associated with slow integration and a
large spatial receptor field associated
with fast integration and also these
other two properties of number density
and gain sensitivity
okay so that's a summary just a
qualitative summary of the of the the oh
and these come in on and off flavors so
that gives you four cell types
okay so how can we explain this from
first principles okay so the strategy we
followed
is we asked
what if the retina was trying to
optimally process natural movies we have
to look at natural movie statistics
because we're trying to explain this
intertwining between space and time so
here you have a natural movie okay we
have a model of the retina that consists
of a convolutional neural network that
is there's a bunch of cells all of the
same cell type so this is a retina that
only has one cell type
right each of these cells has a
spatio-temporal linear filter that that
it uses to process natural movies
right and and since it's the same cell
type it's the same filter copied across
all of the cells
okay now we ask how well does this model
retina do in terms of processing or
well we try to literally decode the
natural movie and try to reconstruct it
using an optimal linear decoder and we
measure performance as a function of the
filter
right and then we optimize the filter to
try to find the best possible retina
with one cell type okay
we can compare that to another model
retina that might have two cell types
right one cell type with one spatial
temporal filter the blue one the this on
the right and another cell type um
the orange one
uh with an with another filter and we
jointly optimize both filters okay
we'd like to ask can you do better with
two cell types say on the right retina
than with one cell type on the left
retina
and we do an apples-to-apples comparison
we hold the number of neurons in the
left fret and on the right retina the
same and we have the overall firing rate
uh
in in the left and right retina the same
so we do an apples-to-apples comparison
and we ask do you do better in
representing the movie using two cell
types in one now what what do we feed in
for the movie well this is a simple
linear model of the retina so that all
that matters for up for what the optimal
filter is
is the space-time power spectrum of
natural movies as that's shown in panel
b if you look at the left
so
that this is a heat map of the
space-time power spectrum of natural
movies
k represents spatial frequency omega
represents temporal frequency and the
structure of natural movies is such that
it has this
power loss structure with two extreme
tails
one tail at the bottom right at high
spatial frequency and low temporal
frequency and one tail at the top left
at low spatial frequency and
high temporal frequency okay this is the
structure of natural movies now we can
actually analytically solve for the
optimal filters for one and two cell
types or more cell types and this is
what we find we find that you do better
with two cell types than you do with one
and why is that is because the two cell
types of different filters can
specialize to the two lobes of the power
spectrum of natural movies
okay so if you look at the bottom right
lobe at right it has that corresponds to
[ __ ] cells in the following sense
the spatial temporal filter will be
concentrated in high spatial frequencies
so it'll be narrow in space
so it'll have a small receptive field
and therefore it's forced to concentrate
on low temporal frequencies so it's slow
in time or slow to integrate
you have to have the receptive fields
tile space so if the receptor field is
small
in order to tile space you need many
many cells
but if you have many many such [ __ ]
cells then they in order to not bust
your firing rate budget remember we're
optimizing filters while constraining an
overall firing rate
in order to not bust your firing rate
budget they can't fire very much okay so
that has the properties of [ __ ] cells
we'll get much more quantitative in the
next slide i'm being qualitative for now
just to explain it on the other hand if
you think about the upper uh
upper left lobe right the parasol cell
filters focus on that part of this power
spectrum of natural movies
and so their filters have low spatial
frequency which means they're wide in
space
and they also have to they're forced to
focus on high temporal frequency because
that's where the power in natural movies
is and so there uh they have rapid
integration or actually slightly
differentiation
so because the receptor field is large
you don't need that many of them to tile
space so you can get away with few cells
and because there are not that many of
them
you can have them fire a lot without
busting your firing rate budget
okay
then we actually became quantitative all
right oops this is a much smaller than
uh
but anyways um
in this figure what you're looking at
is you're looking at a comparison
between the optimal
retina that we find now using a
nonlinear model of the retina where each
cell is modeled with a an ln model so
it's a spatial filter followed by a
rectifying nonlinearity
and then the four optimal cell types
that we derive on the left from
simulation
are are very similar to off and on
[ __ ] and parasol cells so in the
leftmost column you see the spatial
receptive field
in the second from the left column you
see the temporal receptive field
now the two on the right you see
actually data
collector from e.j chichalinsky's lab at
stanford where you have actual receptive
fields of [ __ ] and parasol cells and
you can see there's a really nice
quantitative match between them
so what this is suggesting
is that if you were to try to derive the
retina as an optimal convolutional
autoencoder of natural movies
and you allowed yourself four cell types
these are by the way black and white
movies and if you allowed yourself four
cell types you would actually get
something that looks awfully a lot like
the primate retina now the
next most dominant cell type in the
primary retina is a small by stratified
cell type which actually has color
it differentially processes color
and in more recent work on published
work we've been extending expand um
expanding this work to address natural
color movies and we find a small by
stratified cell type popping out from
our simulations and optimization
okay so this suggests that the cell type
structure of the retina is dictated by
the structure of natural movies which is
really interesting
okay
so um
let's see
okay so now the the third vignette
um is deriving a theory for the
obligatory emergence of grid cells from
biology possible neural circuits that
path integrate
okay
so
um as a mouse moves through a 2d arena
there are cells in the media and toronto
cortex that fire if and only if the
mouse is of the vertices of a hexagonal
grid these are the famous grid cells
that got the node the mosers and o'keefe
also replace cells in nobel prize in
physiology
but
a natural question then is well who
ordered that
why deep in the brain are there these
crystalline hexagonal firing fields
why did evolution order grid cells what
might their purpose be
okay
um
cells
they they don't exist at the sensory
periphery we only get low level pitter
patter of photoreceptor activation
patterns in the retina proprioception
effort motor commands and we have to
construct through a circuit
cells that have these grid cell uh
firing fields
so a hypothesis that we followed you
know a function of median enter on
cortex
is thought to be path integration
though one can debate whether or how
much evidence there is for that function
but that's that's a common function that
median electronic cortex is thought to
play a role in
so natural hypothesis might be
any neural network trained to path
integrate will create internal
representations corresponding to
hexagonal grids
so does the function of a network i.e
potentially path integration determine
its structure or the structure of the
firing fields of cells in the circuit
we weren't the first to pursue this
hypothesis so these two papers train
neural networks to convert velocity
inputs
into positional outputs
and the left work got square grid cells
in a square environment and the right
work got very heterogeneous cells
uh in a in a square environment
um so we asked can you really get
hexagonal grid cells as you know if you
train a neural network in this fashion
okay
and we did find it and we found the key
idea
is to
enforce a very simple biological
constraint that firing rates are
positive
so if you train a recurrent neural
network on the bottom left
and you you feet well what we did was we
trained a recurrent neural network on
the bottom left and we fed it as input
the velocity of a mouse moving through a
square container
okay and
we gave it training data of place field
firing uh you know so we demanded the
net network generate a place field
firing code
and then we just train the recurrent
weights and the feed forward weights of
this neural network to mediate that
transformation
and then we examined the firing fields
of these hidden units inside the neural
network and out popped very beautiful
structured hexagonal grid cells
right so navigation plots is a simple
biochemical constraint implies hexagonal
grid cells now this is still as of yet
an observation without a theory
why does this actually happen
okay
we actually developed a complete
mathematical theory
to explain why these hexagonal grid
cells emerged in our work and why square
or heterogeneous grid cells emerged in
previous work i can't go into the the
full theory in detail but if you're
interested it's worked out in these two
papers here
the basic intuition
is that the uh neural network likes to
learn the
the dominant fourier modes in the place
cell representation and if you enforce a
positivity on the firing rates that
introduces a constraint in panel i on
which fourier modes it can use
in particular it can only use fourier
modes that sum to that sit on the
vertices of an equilateral triangle and
summing fourier modes that's whose wave
vectors sit on the vertices of the
glottal triangle yields the hexagonal
grid cells in panel j
again i don't expect you to really
understand
because the theory is quite involved but
if you're interested
you can read those papers
okay
so let me end now with the last topic
which is um
this is also a little bit smaller for
some reason so we derive and this will
again just be an advertisement we derive
a simple theory of how neural circuits
can recon recapitulate diverse
psychology experiments on the
development of semantic categories in
infants
okay so this is motivated by discussions
i had with my colleague in the
psychology department at stanford james
mcclelland who wrote this very with
timothy rogers wrote this very beautiful
book called semantic cognition i highly
recommend it
i bought it myself and read it to learn
about jay's work and it it highlights a
range of really really interesting
psychology experiments
uh revealing remarkable regularities and
how infants learn semantic concepts okay
just one example of this regularity is
infants learn semantic concepts from a
course
to fine
level of distinction
for example early on very early in age
you know after a few months
even if you control for perceptual
similarity infant can distinguish the
difference between animals and plants
but you have to wait till they get a
little bit older before they can
discriminate different types of animals
like birds and fish
and different types of plants like trees
and flowers and then as they get older
and older they can make finer and finer
scale perceptual discriminations or
semantic discriminations
okay so what jay did in a very beautiful
body of work
is that he trained neural networks
to predict
semantic properties of a set of objects
for example different types of birds
animals and so forth and he watched the
internal representations of these neural
networks develop
through training and this was a model
for for for instance for infant semantic
development and what he find found so
these are trajectories a low dimensional
visualization
of the trajectories of hidden
representations of the neural network
while the neural network is trained to
learn about properties or basically
answer questions
about different types of animals and
birds and so forth and you can see that
these trajectories in the center of this
plot the trajectories
rapidly diverge
all the animals move to the upper left
and all the plants move to the the
bottom right
then there's a later divergence where
the fish separate from the birds and a
later divergence where the
trees separate from the flowers and then
even later individual uh animals and
plants separate right so there's the
same hierarchical unfolding of structure
that that occurs in the hidden
representations neural network
similar to how they occur in infants the
first time i saw this i was once
astounded
uh um because it worked so well
and and be disturbed because
a simple neural network could recon a
simple non-linear neural lab could
recapitulate what infants do at a at a
qualitative level okay so we wanted to
understand uh how this worked and so in
a paper with andrew sacks and j mccollum
we um
in this pns paper at the bottom we
developed a mathematical theory that
explained why this happened and
basically what happens is
coarse distinctions yield a powerful
statistical signal to that neural
networks are capable of picking up on
neural networks with hidden layers are
capable of picking up on
and finer distinctions yields a weaker
signal and we can mathematically um
derive how fast various things we
learned as a function of these signals
and what you're seeing here on the right
is an a plot of an analytic expression
for how internal representations will
evolve in a one hit and layer linear
network exposed to the same training
data
similar training data as the non-the
neural network on the left and you can
see that that we um we can extract what
happens so this is really the difference
between uh
simulations and theory right the
simulations can recapitulate the
phenomena but they don't explain why it
occurs
and on the right we have the theory that
explains why it occurs and you can get
all the details of this paper
there's a similar kind of phenomena also
in the um
in the uh
grid cell work
right
up until now when we train the neural
network and we get uh
and we get these hexagonal grid cells
um you know that's
that's an observation but we don't
understand how it works and we need to
go further to do theory of this fashion
here
in order to explain what happens and
something similar happens i'll just go
full steam back to the
something similar happens
with this um
with the retina
right um
you know once we have the complex neural
circuit in the center we still don't
even though it accurately predicts the
retinal response to natural movies we
still don't understand how it works so
we have to do further theory and in this
case algorithmic advances to extract a
conceptual understanding of how this
works and this will be um
i think one of the central activities of
the nih brain initiative if i go back to
my first slide as we move forward
we have large-scale recordings and
stimulation in place
we have computational methods of
training neural networks either to mimic
the brain or to derive it from first
principles on training on a task in
place we have advances in artificial
intelligence what we do not have yet are
algorithmic methods to go from
large-scale data and complex models to
conceptual understanding
and moreover we don't even have a
conceptual understanding of what
successful conceptual understanding
would even look like that's to be meta
in some sense and so i think as we go
forward to the next decade of the brain
initiative
these issues of what is the nature of
explanation in neuroscience and how do
we most efficiently arrive at it how do
we design experiments to arrive at it
efficiently how do we do analyses to
arrive at it efficiently we'll come to
the fore and i think it'll be incredibly
exciting as we deal with these thorny
conceptual issues